[Musique]
ces travailleurs mexicains viennent ici
depuis plusieurs années pour aider aux
récoltes sur les fermes maraîchères
il arrive parfois qu'il découvre une
bien drôle d'excroissances sur les épis
qui peut en rebuter plusieurs mais qui
représente une denrée très recherchées
chez eux
le 8 la coacher au charbon du maïs est
un parasite qui transforme les grains et
leur donne une apparence pas très
appétissante et pourtant mexique on
l'appelle celles comme le caviar
la troupe mexicaine aussi à l'appel
c'est au goût délicieux sa côte en paix
comme la terre noire salaire comme la
terre n'est pas vraiment bon mais quand
tous les goûts et les saveurs c'est
incroyable kate et will maureen arellano
et chef traiteur à montréal
cuisiner lewitt la coache est une fierté
pour elle j'étais petit mes parents de
me donner à goûter les wheat la coacher
et c'était incroyable
et après ça j'ai les manger souvent au
restaurant
et si on a commencé à faire les
quesadillas elle nous propose plusieurs
variations typique de plats avec le oui
l'a coaché
on va faire face à l'égard des paiements
bon avec et sauve à kkr et on va faire
une salsa verde pour la caisse à dia
c'est 60 et quand
oui c'est plus qu'un lot célé vite la
coach kevin un concert on va mettre sous
l'acacia et va chauffer les huit la cote
chez les vrais matchs à tout en même
temps
l'idée c'est toujours de faire quelque
chose qui est pas beaucoup de savoir
pour toujours et hôtels et votre coach
est toujours sens bien son meilleur
parce que les huit la coach a beaucoup
beaucoup portaient alors ses photos ses
plaies et les bosses c'est l'ego de la
terre c'est pas un ce point nous ferons
peut pas dire que ça goûte le champignon
c'est un peu dur à définir visuellement
je me dis oh boy
mais non non c'est délicieux je
comprends pourquoi les mixed games la
cuisine mexicaine s'inspire aussi de la
cuisine française
la craie pour la phase i avec les huit
la coach la sauce avec les clés pour le
nom avec un peu d'oignons est plein
comme un boulet on va sauter les huit la
coacher mais il faut pas sauter trop
longtemps il faut les garder le plus
frais possible et le maïs
on va mettre même table tous mais très
vite la coacher et si tout peut décider
si tu aimes et est ce autre chose comme
ceux de suisse à un peu bonne
dégustation
crêpes avec les huit la coache sauce au
peuple à nos prochaines recettes ça va
être les relâcher
c'est une page qui est fait avec moi
c'est la farine de maïs
bon on va mettre les rites la coacher
dans l'eure la flèche comme dernier tour
clem aux rites la coache du québec
mam est le pari qu on est sur une ferme
en montérégie
comme beaucoup de fermes au québec on
accueille des travailleurs étrangers ici
à beaucoup de mexicains alors on les a
invités à venir faire une petite bouchée
est venue de cela la commune une
surprise bien apprécié par les
compatriotes de marie laisse place à
leuna la pièce pour la crème alaouites
la coache d'activer québec
il est vrai qu'il a pris corps c'est à
la mairie sur ce que savait hier de 8 la
coach sms que les passerais bien que la
salsa est offert dans ton travail de
chef de prétend essaie de convaincre les
agriculteurs de ne pas jeter les
fameuses épi sur lesquels on a dit oui
de la coacher oui c'est ça pour les
familles que je parlais avec mehdi non
ça c'est là qu'on poste et on a commencé
on peut la conversation des hoquets
arrête ça dans sa recherche et l'a
beaucoup chef mexicaine à montréal qui
sont intéressés aux télés c'est le
propre des locaux mais il faut trouver
on achète au prix dans un champ de maïs
et c'est une épice ursin oui quelqu'un
qui va les chercher qu'il vous apporte
doublé 20 face et maureen arellano
espère vivement faire apprécier et
découvrir ce champignon particulier aux
québécois
[Applaudissements]